bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france une réparation
financière c'est ce que demandent les
victimes d'abus sexuels
or l'église vide et donc ses fidèles est
ce que ça veut dire que ce sont les
fidèles qui vont réparer les dégâts dont
ils sont victimes pourquoi aussi est ce
qu une réparation financière est elle si
importante à leurs yeux
non alors jean marc sauvé que je connais
pour être quelqu'un de très brillant
nous avons passé le diplôme de sciences
po la même année en 1970 il était au
conseil d'état et cetera 10 président
directeur général du gouvernement jean
marc sauvé qui a été aussi deux ans chez
les jésuites avant d'en sortir a dit
clairement qu'on ne devait rien demandé
aux fidèles il a dix fois raison il faut
arrêter de demander à des gens qui sont
absolument étranger à ces scandales de
payer pour ceux qui les ont commis
problème avec le virus l'église de
france est en déficit partout dans les
diocèses dans les paroisses pour vous
donner un seul exemple l'un des
monuments les plus visités au monde
c'est le sacré coeur de montmartre
il y avait 11 millions de visiteurs en
2019 si on a eu cinquante fois moins
l'an dernier d'autre part n'oublions pas
que le pape lui même a arrêté ou presque
d'envoyer d'argent l'afrique parce que
le vatican est en fort déficit des
oeuvres pontificales normes plus les
victimes des abus sexuels
nous vivons une paille et des mises et
c'est un énorme problème
on attendait la réaction du vatican sans
devoir indemniser comment et combien
d'abord avant ne parlait jamais
l'indemnisation mais de compensation
financière maintenant les indemnisations
qui va payer ça ce n'est absolument pas
réglé mais jean-marc sauvé a largement
raison de parler de cela le porte parole
du vatican s'est donc exprimé un propos
qui y était très attendu il a déclaré
que les pensées du pape je cite se
tourner en premier lieu vers les
victimes elles se tournent aussi vers
l'église de france afin qu'elle puisse
entreprendre la voie de la rédemption
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
alors c'est très difficile à dire
d'abord parce que le pape françois n'est
probablement plus pas pour très
longtemps vu son âge et son état de
santé
ensuite parce que le pape a trouvé la
solution qui consiste à dire désormais
les décisions seront prises de manière
synodale c'est-à-dire communautaire par
exemple on pourrait dire le célibat des
prêtres est facultatif dans certains
pays si la conférence épiscopale de ce
pays il accepte et elle demeure
obligatoire
ce célibat si on n'en veut pas dans
certains pays c'est une possibilité il
ya toutes sortes de possibilités
possibles et imaginables mais il ya 1,6
mme quasiment certain de l'église
catholique et 4 est littéralement qui
exploserait si on impose aujourd'hui la
suppression
de l'obligation du célibat d'autre part
n'oublions pas qu'il ya les religieuses
dont certaines ont été victimes
de prêtres mais n'oublions pas non plus
que prêtres et religieuses ont le droit
d'avoir une vie amoureuse et que par
conséquent il est assez normal que par
exemple un père à des kits son avis pour
se marier avec la mère abbesse jalabi
d'à côté on peut pas interdire aux
membres du clergé d'être amoureux mais
pas de commettre des agressions sur des
mineurs c'est ça la difficulté il ne
faut pas dire indéfiniment il n'y a pas
de sexualité pour les prêtres selon le
droit de rien faire c'est intenable
c'était pas la sphère de brebis galeuses
dans le rapport pointe du doigt on l'a
entendu un phénomène au caractère
systémique ce sont les termes qui ont
été utilisés quelle solution aujourd'hui
est ce que ces solutions peuvent venir
de ceux là même qui sont pointés du
doigt à savoir les évêques qui
représente donc le degré suprême de la
hiérarchie ecclésiastique
écouter les évêques sont très partagés
il ya un évêque un sérum remarquable
cemal qui est évêque de gap lorsqu'il
est arrivé à 3 ans dans son diocèse il a
fait un compte en regardant toutes les
archives il a dit en gros il ya eu deux
ou trois prêtres ça représentait 2 ou 3
% des prêtres qui ont commis des actes
qui ne sont pas corrects du tout mais 97
ou 98 % des prête noms rien commis il
faut pas se mettre à accuser les prêtes
quand d'après le rapport sauvé l'immense
majorité est innocente par contre
certains ont commis des actes totalement
inadmissible et là on évite pas à la
grande question pourquoi certains ont
été protégés la réponse est différente
selon les pays la france et 2,5 pour
cent des catholiques baptisé dans le
monde entier et qu'est ce qu'on en pense
dans les autres pays en afrique on dit
souvent à vous nous accusez nous prêtres
africains d'avoir une copine et d'avoir
des enfants mais vous vous tapez les
gauches voyez un peu le genre de
problème le rapport sauvé un asséné puis
pourquoi et comment russie et l'irma
fois les peuples ans marié pourquoi pas
les prêtres pour revenir sur le rapport
sauvé il a asséné que l'église
catholique avait manifesté jusqu'au
début des années 2000 une différence
profonde et même cruel à l'écart à
l'égard des victimes ce sont là encore
les termes employés qu'est-ce qui a été
mise en oeuvre ces dernières années
depuis les années 2000 qu'est-ce qu'ils
étaient mises en oeuvre au sein de
l'église pour que de tels faits de
pédocriminalité ne puisse plus produire
alors ce qui a été fait dans l'église
c'est d'abord que certains évêques y en
a eu trois ont été condamnés pour ne pas
avoir admis que et des prêtres avaient
commis des actes illégaux des actes
immoraux et que par conséquent à défaut
d'être complices ils n'ont pas accompli
leur devoir non pas d'évêque mais leurs
devoirs tout simplement de citoyens
ensuite il faut dire que chargé
d'affaires comme à lyon la sphère du
père prenne à elle soutient ont quand
même révélé l'ampleur du problème un
évêque de plus être indifférent personne
ne l'accepterai toutefois il faut bien
voir que dans ce contexte là on doit
bien distinguer les choses et il faut
reconnaître que la grande majorité des
prêches sont innocents et c'est eux qui
payent pour les fautes des autres c'est
inadmissible c'est encore les prêtres du
diocèse d'orléans on leur avait demandé
de cons qu'on pardonne ce qu'avaient
fait les prêts ils ont dit nous on n'a
rien fait on va pas demander pardon aux
innocents bon c'est très compliqué les
évêques ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
sur ce plan là il ya des risques de
désaccords profonds et puis d'autre part
les fidèles non plus sont pas d'accord
ceux qui sont les plus conservateurs
disent il faut oublier tout ça
ceux qui sont plus ouverts 10 il ne faut
pas oublier la commission sauvé avec sa
vice-présidente véronique magro
remarquable religieuse la commission a
raison de dire on ne doit pas laisser ça
sans conséquences sérieuses un tout
dernier notamment le célèbre et du pénal
parce que le temps nous manque le tout
dernier mot ces thèmes du biquet ce look
de l'img les gens ne vaut rien et
s'occupe pas des victimes un tout
dernier mot publication de ces rapports
vous diriez dis chiche vol la
conséquence ou bien est-ce que cette
publication finalement c'est le point de
départ d'une page qui se tourne pour
l'église catholique est ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer que ce moment que vit
l'église ouvre la porte au moins un vrai
questionnement vous l'évoquiez à la fois
sur le mariage des prêtres mais aussi
sur la place des femmes dans les
instances raffault gouvernance au sein
de l'institution
tout à fait
à jour de deuil pour l'église catholique
c'est le pire jour qu'elle ait connu au
moins depuis 120 ans cela étant ça va
forcer l'église catholique à faire un
travail de fond en sachant que les
autres religions ont aussi les mêmes
problèmes il ya eu d
des comportements de ce type chez des
protestants cd orthodoxe et 18 chez des
musulmans chez les bouddhistes et cetera
et cetera et puis si des gens qui n'ont
aucune religion également vous voyez
c'est très très vaste n'accusons pas
seulement l'église catholique mais elle
doit absolument faire des réformes
immédiates et profonde merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions sur un rt france dont valais
je rappelle que vous êtes historien des
religions merci